تلبية للدعوة إلى التوحد تحت
علم واحد، هذا هو مصدر مجدنا، لقد
كان إنتاج إعلامي بارع لداعش يرعب
العالم، هذا
ما أرادوا منا أن نراه
ولكن ليس هذا،
هذا الفيلم مختلف، هذا الفيلم هو
تنظيم الدولة الإسلامية دون أن يعرفه تنظيم الدولة الإسلامية.
تم تصوير
فيديو لم يسبق له مثيل داخل
مقر الجماعة في مدينة
حلب السورية في عام 2013، وهو مستشفى للأطفال
تحول إلى منزل لحورس. فيديو من كاميرات المراقبة
يصور واقع
الدولة الإسلامية حيث كان التعذيب روتينيًا، حيث
تم احتجاز مئات السوريين في هذا المكان
المؤقت.  لم يتمكن الكثيرون من الخروج من السجن مطلقًا
لسرد قصصهم، كما
فعل آخرون، بما في ذلك بعض
الرهائن الغربيين، بروايات مرعبة عما
نجوا منه وشهدوه، وكان بإمكاننا
سماع السجناء السوريين في
الأماكن الأولى التي تم احتجازنا فيها في
مستشفى حلب، على سبيل المثال، كان بإمكاننا
رؤية بعض من  لهم في الممرات
ويمكننا أن نرى بعض الناس يرقدون في
دمائهم، هذا الفيديو هو أكثر بكثير من مجرد
لقطة من عهد الإرهاب الذي يمارسه داعش كحالة
عادية،
كان المستشفى به كاميرات مراقبة تديرها
أعضاء الدولة الإسلامية لم
يدركوا ذلك  تم تسجيل هذا في
الخلفية ولم أفكر كثيرًا
في الأمر، وتدحرجت الكاميرات لعدة
أشهر لالتقاط مشاهد كهذه، أسير
معلق في
وضع مرهق، معتقلون معصوبو الأعين يسيرون في
الردهة هنا مقاتل يضحك
وهو يدفع رأسه إلى أسفل  لمعتقل مكبل
اليدين ومغطى الرأس، هذه
فقط بعض المقاطع التي تمت مشاركتها
حصريًا مع CNN من قبل لجنة
العدالة الدولية
والمساءلة، هذا هو بالضبط
نوع المعاملة التي سمعنا
عنها من الناجين، ما يجعل هذا الأمر
مهمًا هو كما ترى بشكل صحيح  هناك
عضو الدولة الإسلامية بدون قناع
يسير في القاعة، وهو شخص
يحاول عادة إخفاء
وجهه في الخارج، لقد
قمنا بطمس الوجوه للحفاظ على
التحقيقات الجارية في
الملاحقات القضائية المستقبلية المحتملة، وهذا دليل لا يصدق
في المحاكمة للعديد من هؤلاء
الأفراد الذين  تم التعرف عليه
وفقًا لمقاتلي إنجل من جميع أنحاء
العالم بما في ذلك أعضاء كبار
من أوروبا والولايات المتحدة الذين كانوا يعملون
في المنشأة، ويقول إن هذا الفيديو قد تم
استخدامه بالفعل لتحديد هوية مشتبه به فرنسي،
وقد سمحت لهم الأدلة التي تم جمعها منذ فترة طويلة
بإنفاذ القانون في مختلف الدول الغربية.
الدول لتحديد وتعقب
أعضاء داعش الذين فروا قبل سقوط ما
يسمى بحصار داعش،
عمل محققو جرائم الحرب سرًا على
جمع أدلة مثل هذه من ساحات
القتال في سوريا والعراق،
غالبًا ما يكون لدى
سلطات إنفاذ القانون أو سلطات الادعاء المحلية
أدلة كافية  لإثبات أنهم
كانوا أعضاء، ما نعتقد أنه مهم
هو أنه حيثما أمكن ذلك، سنكون قادرين على
مقاضاتهم بتهمة التعذيب
والاختطاف والقتل،
وهذا لا يتعلق فقط بالماضي، حيث
يظل داعش يمثل تهديدًا أمنيًا عالميًا كبيرًا،
هؤلاء هم الأفراد الذين  لقد
أثبتوا بالفعل أنهم يشكلون تهديدًا
ولا نريد أن نمنحهم الفرصة
ليقرروا السير في هذا الطريق مرة أخرى، لقد تلقينا
عدة مئات من الطلبات للحصول على معلومات،
ولم ينس شركاؤنا في مجال إنفاذ القانون على الإطلاق
الصراع
في يناير  نزلت الشرطة الهولندية السابعة عشرة المدججة بالسلاح
في هذا الشارع في
قرية أركو، وداهمت منزلاً
واعتقلت رجلاً يشتبه في أنه
أحد كبار قادة داعش في سوريا، وتم
اعتقاله في البلدة الصغيرة الهادئة
حيث كان يعيش حياة هادئة مع
زوجته وأطفاله.  لقد صدمت الأمة حيث
كان السكان هنا مترددين في التحدث
إلينا عن المشتبه به الذي تم تحديده على أنه "
العامل" لأنه يُزعم أنه يعمل في
دمشق وليس حلب، لذا لم يكن
فيديو CCTV هو الذي أدى إلى اعتقاله، بل كانت
نصيحة من منظمة غير حكومية سورية وشهادة شاهدة على
ذلك  أثار
تحقيقًا هولنديًا دام سنوات،
تقول مصادر إن لديه تاريخًا طويلًا من
التطرف في سوريا، حيث شغل
مناصب قيادية في البداية داخل إحدى الجماعات
التابعة لتنظيم القاعدة ثم في وقت لاحق في تنظيم داعش الإرهابي، الذي
يرفض اتهامات الحكومة
ويواجه الآن السجن مدى الحياة، وكان يشغل
منصبًا قياديًا داخل تنظيم داعش.
المنظمات الإرهابية ميريام بلوم هي
المدعي العام الرئيسي في القضية التي
وجهت إليه تهمتين
بالعضوية في منظمات إرهابية
بهدف ارتكاب جرائم حرب من أجل
اتهامه بجرائم حرب منفصلة
مثل الإعدام أو الاعتقالات العنيفة أو أو
التعذيب الذي
تحتاجه  أدلة أكثر من المؤشرات،
وبالتالي فإن هذا مستمر ولدينا تحقيق لا يزال مستمرًا، نعم هل كان
يختبئ ولم يكن مختبئًا، كان
يعيش هناك علنًا أشخاص مثله
وأيضًا كان المجرمون يأتون إلى
هولندا مختبئين في
التدفق الشرعي من  اللاجئين وأن نكون قادرين على
التحقيق في هذه الحالات ومحاكمتها هو
جانب مهم جدًا في
مهمتنا ألا نكون ملاذًا آمنًا لمجرمي الحرب. إن
مسار الإرهاب الذي خلفه داعش
لن يطارد ضحاياهم فحسب، بل أيضًا
أولئك الذين عذبوهم.